Kanye West not wasting any time
following his divorce from Kim
Kardashian we have different views
sometimes TMZ was first to report the
embattled rapper has sort of tied the
knot with Bianca sensory with the two
taking part in a marriage ceremony over
the weekend but it is not legally
binding the outlet says no certificate
has been filed with the government at
least not yet so that rumored weddings
likely more about showing commitment to
one another than actually becoming
husband and wife this comes as yay's
still mid-controversy following his
string of anti-Semitic messages in
interviews and on social media the thing
about it me and Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me now what
now what so details are few and far
between on Kanye's new love but here's
what we do know for one thing this
likely began as an office romance Bianca
actually works at Yeezy the rapper's
fashion label now according to the
20-somethings LinkedIn profile she has
been on the payroll since 2020 and her
title head of architecture though it's
unclear why the brand would need an
architect seeing as it's only done
clothing up until now I have an opinion
as for her credentials she earned a
master's degree in architecture in her
native Australia at the University of
Melbourne and in between classes Bianca
created a jewelry company as she told ID
magazine at the time quote once I
started architecture I still wanted some
sort of creative outlet and it grew into
a business
and how about the title of Kanye's
latest track sensory overload fans are
singling out one verse in particular and
the Bible said I can't have any more sex
till marriage the lyrics invite plenty
and speculation but it remains to be
seen if the sentiment led to Kanye and
Bianca's alleged eye dues
in the middle
as of now there's no reaction from the
Kardashian Camp Kim and Kanye officially
settled their divorce back in November
nearly two years after proceedings began
to end the ex's six-year marriage
they'll share joint custody of their
children with equal access though Kim
will have their four kids a majority of
the time having kids is just there's no
way to describe it but it's a lot and
the settlement confirmed Kanye will pay
two hundred thousand dollars per month
in child support co-parenting it's
really hard you know in Kim's chat on
the Angie Martinez IRL podcast last
month she got candid about her
post-divorce mindset I feel free in the
sense
that I am not anybody else
I don't hold anyone else's
thoughts opinions burdens
and I used to hold this guilt that I
wasn't there
to fix situations and I wasn't there
to put it all back together or to
I'm I'm free
[Music]